with the Green Party are on a bit of a
roll after a strong showing in last
month's European elections joining us
now from their spring conference in
Scarborough is the party's co-leader
Sean Barie thank you for being on the
program this morning and now the last
time we spoke you were going after good
performs the local elections you didn't
do quite so violent Peter Bratt de digi
you only got three percent of the vote
and you worried that people are happy to
vote for green a protest vote in the
European elections and the local
elections but not when it really matters
when they're choosing their own people
well I'm Peter Brooke we do have
councillors elected and that was
actually our best ever result in a
parliamentary election there in a
by-election so you can't dent my
enthusiasm about our recent results not
when actually for Westminster polls
we're now polling 9 to 11 percent that's
a really really high number of people
one in 10 people saying they will vote
green for Westminster under
first-past-the-post as we currently have
it that's places where we can win new
seats right there in the European
elections we came first in places like
Norwich and Bristol obviously Brighton
where we already have an MEP MP but also
we were second behind parties that
everyone would want us to be in places
like Sheffield and Lancaster we've got a
whole new set of targets now and a whole
new load of MEP is elected to a
fantastic and MPs in Waiting we're a
very very enthusiastic party at the
moment at our conference here in
Scarborough and we're making plans for
that for the next steps this this
success has been a long time coming
isn't a flash in the pan it isn't a
protest vote we've had people working on
the ground for many years we've been
electing counselor after councilor local
champions who are fighting for local
services in the face of austerity and
those people are trusted people are now
getting used to voting green again and
again I can't see us going backwards
from this and everyone here is very
enthusiastic about the future you
recently said that the Lib Dems are part
of the old politics criticizing them for
signing up to an austerity program but
quite helped thinking you'd have done an
awful lot better in Peterborough
wouldn't you if you'd actually teamed up
with the Lib Dems aren't they your
natural allies that you should be
looking to do deals with certainly we're
working with them on the people's boat
campaign
when it came to the European elections
it was really important that we looked
at the total sum of all the parties who
were arguing with remaining on that with
the Lib Dems we couldn't agree more but
they can't hide from their history and
their record we are rivals with them and
we are entitled to point that out these
are just facts that austerity was an
enormous mistake that's caused huge
amounts of harm right across the country
local councils have been squeezed to the
bone they've cut back on their services
and there is genuine harm to hundreds of
thousands of millions of people across
the country thanks to these cuts to
libraries to youth services to health
visitors to social care in pointing out
the harm that that caused and asking
them to say it was a huge mistake we're
not doing anything wrong
and they are not actually going back on
that policy now Joseph Winston said that
austerity had to happen well will we
disagree we disagreed from the start and
we're there to point that out we've
called all the recent issues in politics
right from braixen to austerity to
climate change and people are catching
up with us ok in the son of a Sunday
this morning you've told the newspaper
that you have previously done drugs in
the past are you not worried about the
environmental impact of this I mean
cocaine for example was doing immense
damage to the rainforests yeah no now I
am I wasn't planning a political career
when I was young and I did try cocaine
once and if I had better education about
its effects I wouldn't have because they
I hated it and now I know I mean as a
politician now I work on policing in
London I know the enormous harm that is
caused by the illegal drugs market
there's people suffering from addiction
for which they need treatment and then
we've got the the huge harm caused to
young people the devastating impact of
violence on young people which is driven
by the illegal drugs market which is
left at the moment in the hands of
organized crime we have to take an
evidence-based public health approach
it's good the politicians are being
honest about our past and our
involvement in this and being honest
about what needs to change is what's
important in drugs we have to take the
evidence-based approach the green policy
is to look at this from the point of
view of evidence and public health based
on
suppose for this issue on treatment on
education on regulation and on honesty
okay and just finally and at conference
last year the Green Party didn't adopt
the internationally recognized
definition of anti-semitism this is the
international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance definition the one of course
that Labour controversially didn't adopt
and then subsequently did why has a
Green Party not adopted it and do you
think that you should we were very
strongly anti-racist party and we are
looking at how to adopt that into our
code of conduct and our disciplinary
processes and our wider policies as well
we have a very democratic party and at
the moment that is under review by a
group of people who are looking at that
and looking at a messenger of
Islamophobia as well standing against
hate crime of all kinds is very
important to us what's your passing of
you my personal view is I've been I've
signed up to it mm as part of the London
Assembly and as a local councillor in
Camden the working definition of the
IHRA when it comes to incorporating it
into the technicalities of party
disciplinary processes it just gets a
little bit more complicated so it's
taking time but I think you will not
find greens who say that we are not
against anti-semitism against hate crime
of all kinds we're currently fighting to
get misogyny classified as a hate crime
as well because it is really important
that we have the right laws and the
right penalties when people are using
discrimination as a way of committing
crimes and that if they're allowed to
get away with it that that really does
lead to Alaska he civ society and that's
not what we want to build ok sean barie
from a very beautiful looking
Scarborough thank you for being on the
program